here's a legal pro tip if you admit to
opposing counsel that he's having a
perry mason moment while cross-examining
you this is your perry mason moment well
you're probably screwed and that is
exactly what happened to alex jones alex
jones got so skewered on
cross-examination that the writers of
law and order said it was too
unrealistic for the show now to say that
this defamation trial by some of the
sandy hook families against alex jones
is going poorly for jones is quite the
understatement now to recall how we got
here jones is already in hot water this
trial is only over damages how much
jones is going to have to pay these
families because he and his lawyers
engaged in so many discovery abuses that
the judge sanctioned him gave him
effectively terminating sanctions where
he had to concede liability jones lost
the case and the sandy hook plaintiffs
won by default that's how abusive they
were during discovery but that takes us
to the viral video that you might have
seen clips of where the plaintiff's
attorney mark bankston absolutely
destroys alex jones on cross after just
setting him up for
a gigantic fall so let's take a look
one of the things you talked about
yesterday is you complied with discovery
right
you said that on the witness stand
that's one of the things i talked about
i mean jones did not actually comply
with discovery but i guess now they're
saying after all the sanctions they have
uh upheld all of their obligations okay
one of the things that you were ordered
to do in this lawsuit
your order to turn over any text
messages in the gene sandy hook right
yes yeah so
probably the very first request that the
plaintiffs would have made is
any documents that mention the phrase
sandy hook or refer to the events of
sandy hook that jones possesses this is
discovery 101 these are the kind of
requests you're going to make and you
didn't have any
right not that we can find now that's a
bit of a cop-out by jones he's saying
you know might have had them but we
couldn't find them
that doesn't get out of his obligations
because you have to do a reasonable
search and your lawyers have to make
sure that you do a reasonable search to
find responsive documents and and you in
fact told me in not needing your
testimony sworn testimony before coming
to this courtroom you searched right i
did okay all right so bankston has set
this up you've testified that you didn't
have any uh sandy hook related texts and
that of course you did a search for them
it's
all downhill from here for for jones do
you remember were you here for mr
shorter yesterday oh yes okay you
remember what owen said the company has
learned from its mistakes about sandy
hook you remember that oh i did hear you
say that you agree with that
yeah we certainly learned from our
mistakes got a lot better okay
mr jones i'd like to show you what's
been mark's plan
one third
you've got it upside down
that's text messages between you and
paul watson isn't it
yes and they mention sandy hook don't
they
yeah let us move 130 into evidence all
right so this is the kind of stuff you
never see in movies it's uh the meat and
potatoes of litigation it's kind of the
boring stuff you're laying foundation
that this document is what it purports
to be uh this witness has verified it
and then you're moving it into evidence
but so far seems pretty routine uh we're
about to find out why that is not the
case and it is a brilliant act of
setting everyone up for a fall here
the judge asks any objections no why
would there be any objections this is
probably just one of the millions of
documents that were turned over
plaintiffs 130 is admitted no objection
so uh the opposing counsel uh doesn't
quite uh understand what this document
is at this point and so he waves any
objection he might make to entering this
particular document into evidence now
jones has been screwed let's zoom in on
the little article up in the corner
i'm going to walk over this to you
someone kind of pointed i know it's a
little hard to read you might be able to
read a little better on your screen but
this is a zoom of mr watson has sent you
a screenshot from infowars.com correct
and it says staged
video shows hospital using dummies in er
for coronavirus footage i believe so
let's go to the first message for mr
watson read along with me mr jones he
says this is a video sergeant so no
problem take your time
man jones has a nasty cough i guess he
needs to take more of those supplements
that he hawks on his channel you may not
think it's a problem and it's reeling
sure mr watson says this is a video of a
medical student trying to intubate
makes us look ridiculous suggesting this
means kovid is fake
sandy hook all over again
i'll read that correctly yes
there was a next message
what did you tell mr watson
i get it
what has happened is this is something
that has taken place after all of the
sandy hook related communications
one of his employees says that we
shouldn't publish this because it makes
us look stupid and it's evocative of
what happened during the sandy hook
stuff and jones says i get it everything
jones has said up until now is basically
a lie and it also shows that jones and
his attorneys never actually searched
for responsive communications so being
caught in that particular lie and
falsity is going to be much much worse
than if they had just turned over these
documents in the first place and that is
why you comply with discovery but let's
see
how the knife gets twisted mr jones it's
true
that this article is right now
live on infowars.com hold up right
i've never seen this text message
i guess you guys got polls my phone
didn't save them so that's all right
your phone didn't say the second one i
told you guys i gave it the i gave it to
the lawyers who said they drain the
phone they didn't find that stuff
[Applause]
yeah and now he's trying to throw his
lawyers under the bus uh that uh must
not have been on my phone i searched my
phones and i turned stuff over to
lawyers if you didn't have this it's
because of the lawyers that's not going
to go as planned
they were supposed to find it so that's
what that's your testimony no i
certainly should as well i don't know
it's going to stay in there
i mean i just i turned the phone over
and said take stuff off can i have you
look in the very bottom below the
very bottom left corner
is that the phone number
yes so you did get my text messages
and they said you didn't nice trick
yes mr johnson
indeed the lawyer can't help himself
because he knows what the next question
is going to be
alex jones is trying to uh to run this
really fine line where uh
yes he held stuff back he got sanctioned
so badly that he lost the liability
phase of the trial he thinks it's safe
to say well i couldn't have possibly
held it back if you have all of these
text messages
but now the final phase of the trap is
just about to be sprung you didn't give
this text message to me you don't you
don't know where this came from do you
know where i got this no 12 days ago
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell
phone with every text message you've
sent for the past two years and when
informed
did not take any steps to identify it as
privileged or protected in any way and
as of two days ago it fell free and
clear into my possession and that is how
i know you lied to me when you said you
didn't have to text messages about
saying okay did you know that
i see i told you the truth this is your
perry mason moment i gave them my phone
and then mr jones you need to answer the
question
so
normally there's some professional
courtesy amongst lawyers where you're
not going to just absolutely destroy
them and throw them under the bus here
uh the lawyers is throwing jones and his
attorneys under the bus i've never heard
of something this inflammatory coming
out against another opposing attorney
during the course of a trial the lawyer
screwed up and sent an entire copy of
jones's phone
to opposing counsel and then didn't claw
it back there are a million things that
you can do to claw that back the lawyer
didn't do that as a result alex jones is
on the stand just getting destroyed
being shown that everything he's talked
about is a lie that um they tried to
continue to hide information from the
plaintiffs
and it's only because of this
inadvertent disclosure that they finally
got the documents that they had been
entitled to this entire time the jury is
hearing all of this and they're finding
out how much of a liar and fabulist alex
jones is if they didn't know already but
also that there are shenanigans as well
and
during the course of trial uh not only
the witnesses credibility but the
lawyer's credibility is everything and
once you lose that credibility you're
probably screwed because the jury will
find ways to uh award people that they
believe and punish people who they don't
believe oh and and by the way it's of
course impossible to prep a witness like
alex jones to be an effective advocate
on the stand
um but man you gotta know just the
basics of self-preservation don't tell
the cross-examining attorney that this
is his perry mason moment it kind of
signals to the jury that you're getting
screwed uh and you deserve to be screwed
no i didn't know this happened but i
mean i told you i gave him a phone over
and just said justin
you said in your deposition
you searched your phone
you said you pulled down the text did
the search function for sandy hook and i
had several several different phones
with this number but i did yeah
of course i mean that's why you got it
there's all kinds of things that can go
wrong in discovery but the easiest the
absolute easiest thing that you can do
as a client or as a lawyer is to do a
word search and when the entire trial
revolves around the the phrase sandy
hook the absolute bare minimum the the
the necessary thing that you have to do
is do a word search for sandy hook and
it's very clear that if they had done
this absolute minimum fundamental thing
this text would have been found and it
would have been turned over to the other
side but they
clearly didn't do that mr johnson that's
not what happened
my lawyer said it to you but i'm hiding
it okay mr jones
mr joseph just answered questions
there's no question mr banks can also
only ask questions sure and a little bit
of foreshadowing here
this is really underselling what
happened between the two lawyers that uh
the opposing counsel the defense
attorney
um
sent
the full copy of jones's phone is just
the tip of the iceberg he actually sent
way
way more than that to opposing counsel
effectively probably the entire case
file from the defense to the plaintiffs
just absolute malpractice and we're
going to get to that because that is if
you can believe it even juicier than
this cross-examination is uh is
indicating mr dunce in discovery you
were asked do you have sandy hook text
messages on your phone and you said no
correct i mean i was mistaken i was
mistaken but you've got the messages
right there you know
i just want to make sure you know before
we go any further you know what it is
yes i do i mean i'm not a tech guy i
told you i gave in my testimony the
phone to the lawyers before whatever and
and so you've got my phone but we didn't
give it to you
please remember if you need to do a
certain amendment you can't i mean you
can't do that
that you
personally searched your phone for the
phrase sandy hook and there were no
messages you said that on your own yes
no i did not lie
and here the plaintiff's attorney is
kind of guilting the lily a little bit
he's has now absolutely established that
jones uh said he did a search uh for the
the word sandy hook uh and that he
previously testified that he did not
have any of those communications which
we now know is absolutely not the case
jones tries to backpedal by saying look
i was mistaken i had many phones uh but
uh i thought that was true at the time
but that seems extraordinarily unlikely
under the cross-examination that we just
saw because again you're trying to
impugn the witness's character and show
that the witness is a liar so as mr
bankston has done here you teed up with
a prior inconsistent statement and then
show them either the evidence uh or the
prior statement that is contradictory to
what they previously testified to so
when i saw this clip i was flabbergasted
how in the world did this happen how did
these documents get turned over after
years of being hidden by alex jones and
his attorneys well luckily the court
held a full hearing on this matter to
discuss
jones's counsel finally moved for a
mistrial the day after this testimony
came out now this hearing did not go
well so let's dive into this hearing
because uh from a seasoned litigator i
think this is actually even more
interesting than the original
cross-examination uh so jones's attorney
is asking for a mistrial effectively
he's saying that the uh malfeasance from
the other side is so terrible that we
need to end this trial and do it over
again so how in the world did this
happen well let's hear it straight from
andino reynald the defense attorney's
mouth a couple weeks before trial a file
transfer link was sent to
the plaintiff's attorneys specifically
mr bankston
that link
linked up a lot of files that shouldn't
have been connected to it okay so he's
saying that a link was sent probably a
dropbox link containing some documents
that needed to be turned over to the
plaintiffs apparently that link
contained much much more than was
intended he said i take it this was sent
in error and i responded to him and i
said it it has been sent an error please
disregard the link i will work on
preparing a new one okay so we hear from
the defense attorney that the
plaintiff's attorney did notify him that
the production had been made and it was
probably in air that's super bad news
for the defense attorney because if
you've been notified and you don't do
anything to claw it back uh well then
you're probably screwed which spoiler is
what happens here i mean we have a
situation here which is akin to to me
mistakenly giving him the key to a room
and you know he opens the door to the
room and instead of finding what he
expected to find he sees other doors and
he recognized that and told me i don't
think he meant to give me this key
and i said please throw it away
apparently at some point thereafter um
he said you know what i'd kind of really
like to see what's behind those doors
this is an interesting argument and he's
doing probably a good job of trying to
paint the plaintiff's actions in the
worst possible light because that's what
you're going to need to convince the
judge to claw back all of these
documents he's saying that the
plaintiff's attorney abused
the inadvertent production went
rummaging around in all of these
documents and found what was good for
his case
and i guess didn't notify or destroy the
documents once they were in his
possession
and
that's why we're here seeking protection
under the texas rules of civil procedure
as well as the court's confidential
reality order so here's the relief that
the defense attorney is looking for he's
asking for a protective order to stop
disseminating the documents to claw them
back to assert privilege and to destroy
uh those documents that have been
inadvertently turned over to the
plaintiffs you're right i'm just gonna
start unsending these one by one he
wrote unsend you keep sending the word
unsend unsend unsend unsent please do
not read i'm begging you yeah i hate to
be
put into this position by the conduct
of
plaintiff's council and of course he is
trying to blame plaintiff's attorney for
this mess uh not he himself the one that
inadvertently produced all this stuff
and and that's why in addition to the
request that they
delete the information from their
servers and delete the link um we're
also requesting at this point
unfortunately a mystery and now we hear
from the plaintiff's attorney and hear
his side of it first let me just go
through the facts that clara said
it was this link of materials was sent
to me it was sent to mr ogden it was
sent by a mr reynolds legal assistant ah
okay so this link was sent not by uh
defense attorney andino reynald but
actually by his legal assistant i think
that legal assistant has probably been
fired uh an easy mistake to make but
it's a mistake that you absolutely
cannot make as i informed mr reynold
we started downloading those materials
we i i was busy on chopra i told my
paralegal get these on our server
download everything now all right a
little bit after you down gets this
stuff downloading
it's like wait a second this file that
we now have on our server is has
clogged up our entire server it's like
300 gigs what's going on okay so the
plaintiff's lawyer does what probably
anyone would do you get a link and you
start downloading it and then only once
you've started downloading it do you
realize that it's a huge production 300
gigabytes and you probably don't know
what's in that link until you've
downloaded everything but it's it's so
big that it's actually clogging his
servers which is hilarious uh well not
for jones's attorneys though mr reagan
will actually block quotes 130 193
through 2d
so i know he knows how to read it but he
still hasn't done
at the moment he is up here requesting a
mistrial because he hasn't followed the
rule even today late has not followed
the rule the rule requires
that production is any privilege his way
okay this is easy to miss but this is
the most important part the plaintiff's
attorney is referring to briefing he's
saying that the defense's brief is
citing a part of the texas rule of civil
procedure about inadvertent disclosure
and he's saying
i know that opposing counsel the defense
attorney is able to read because he is
citing to the operative part of the
texas rule of civil procedure
but it actually is very very bad for him
and he talks about the actual standard
what happens when you make an
inadvertent disclosure lawyers write
these rules so
obviously they're going to make it so
that if you inadvertently disclose
something there's a way to get it back
any privilege is waived
if within 10 days
or if you order a shorter time but
within 10 days the producing party of
when they actually discovered so 10 days
from the moment i told them
that they identify specifically the
material or information produced and
state the privilege assertive
i have not heard any privilege
i've never heard a privilege asserted
over any document so the plaintiff's
lawyer points out that he notified
opposing counsel of the disclosure
opposing counsel didn't do anything he
didn't supplement his production he
never asserted privilege that means all
of these documents all 300 gigabytes of
documents are fair game and the
plaintiff's lawyer is probably right but
even more important than that is all of
the stuff in there he cannot now come
into court and claim 2.3 gigabytes of
phone material blanket designation of
confidentiality the protective order
prohibits them you must identify
specifically the documents that are and
and things like like mr jones and his
intimate messages with roger stone are
not confidential then the plaintiff's
lawyer explains that the defense uh not
only failed to uphold their obligations
under 193.3 uh but they didn't comply
with the court's protective order that
the court can put in additional rules
that govern the disclosure of
information they didn't follow that
they didn't supplement their production
so
even the email that says please
disregard that link i'll send you
another link he didn't even follow
through with that
and oh by the way
the vast majority of these documents
are not privileged and should have been
disclosed years and years ago so i don't
think that you have complied with the
protective order
i will let you
do so now
if there are documents and you would
like to mark them as confidential and we
can go through the process
and i can review them and make a
decision but i'm not going to seal the
entire
quantity of information
without knowing what's in it when the
rules weren't followed properly it's a
tremendous amount of information here
i know the problem is it probably should
have been disclosed
a year ago or longer and then there
would have been plenty of time told
through all of it and in the end the
judge doesn't see all these documents
she allows the defense to try to assert
privilege she recognizes that the vast
majority of these documents are not
privileged and should have been turned
over and then of course the defense's
prior discovery abuses come back to bite
them again because how in the world are
they going to
actually assert privilege or review 300
gigabytes worth of files in a couple of
days while at trial
but the judge
doesn't have any sympathy she says that
this stuff should have been turned over
and the reason that they're in this
position is because of their own
malfeasance and the lesson here that
clients learn time and time again is
don't hold back discovery don't engage
in discovery abuses or stuff like this
is going to happen oh and one more thing
at the end of the trial the plaintiff's
lawyer lets the judge and opposing
counsel know
that law enforcement is requesting these
documents and not only law enforcement
but in particular the january 6
committee is very interested in these
documents and he's going to turn them
over to that committee so it looks like
that is just the beginning of alex
jones's legal worries and you'll be able
to read all about alex jones's future
civil and criminal legal issues in
today's sponsor morning brew because
that's my favorite way to catch up with
pop culture and the news i've actually
been subscribed to morning brew for
forever it's one of my absolute favorite
newsletters and i'm thrilled to tell you
why because morning brew if you didn't
already know is a free daily newsletter
delivered monday through sunday it gets
you up to speed on business finance tech
and the law in just five minutes and it
provides a fantastic quick survey of the
most important issues while being witty
irreverent and informative and did i
mention it's completely free this week i
learned all about brittany griner's nine
year sentence in russia zombie pigs who
were brought back to life no that's not
about alex jones and nancy pelosi
landing in taiwan it's basically exactly
the mix of news that i'm actually
interested in and it's all the stuff
that i didn't even know that i wanted to
know about and it's all written in a
hilarious style morning brew is one of
the few emails that i actually open
every single day so legal eagles this
one is a complete no-brainer morning
brew is completely free and it takes
less than 15 seconds to subscribe just
click on the link that's on screen right
now or in the description to get morning
brew for free and not only will you get
a newsletter that you'll actually read
you'll actually help out this channel
too so click on the link below to get
morning brew right away
and after you sign up you should click
on this playlist over here to watch more
illegal eagle or i'll see you in court